Hi, I'm Addy Osmani.
I'm a Senior Developer Relations
Engineer working on Polymer.
Today we're going to take
a look at how to save you
time building components for
the web in fewer lines of code.
Before we dive in, let's
talk about web components.
They're still pretty
new to a lot of people.
So let's make sure we're all
on the same page before we go
and build something.
Web Components are an
emerging set of standards
that allow you to build
new HTML elements.
The APIs are Templates,
Custom Elements, Shadow DOM,
and HTML Imports.
Each one of these APIs
is useful individually.
But when used
together, they enable
developers to be
really productive.
So Polymer helps developers
stay more productive.
What do we mean by productivity?
Well, take a component like
tabs, a pretty common place
component on the web.
You've probably used a tab
component at some point.
Writing a tab component on
the web has changed over time.
Years ago, we
started off in markup
with a little bit of JavaScript.
But since then, we've piled
more and more and more
and even more of our
logic into JavaScript.
Maybe this isn't
the best approach.
Look at the suffering it causes.
Perhaps there's a better
way of doing this.
Using web components
with Polymer,
we could rewrite those
nasty-looking widgets
using a custom HTML element,
which is much more readable.
So, here's what tabs would look
like if they were just HTML.
It's much easier to
see what's going on.
The code is declarative.
It's legible.
And it's descriptive.
Simple, right?
My-tabs is just an element,
something componentized
that's readable,
semantic, and describes
exactly what it offers.
Components are
awesome because they
force us to think
about constructing
web apps as a composition
of components,
rather than a mass of
tightly coupled pieces.
We're no longer looking at
a soup of divs and script.
Now, this is where
Polymer comes in.
Polymer is a new type of
library for the web that
allows you to easily
build applications
based on Web Components.
It includes a set of
polyfills for the native APIs.
So you can start
using them today.
What Polymer really
does is it provides
a convenient and opinionated
layer on top of vanilla web
components, with features
like Two-way data
binding, declarative event
handlers, property observation,
and touch gestures, to help you
quickly build powerful apps.
Great.
So let's build a tabs
element using Polymer.
Let's first take a look
at our completed element.
Our control is both beautiful
and quite functional.
We begin building our first
element using seed-element,
a boilerplate project providing
sample code and structure
to help you get off
the ground quickly.
The boilerplate is available on
GitHub at the following link.
Great.
Once you're on the page
for the repository,
click the Download ZIP button
to download the boilerplate
to your machine.
Next, create a new
directory called development
and a sub-directory
called my-tabs.
Extract the contents of the zip
file to your my-tabs folder.
Next, we'll rename the
files from the boilerplate,
replacing seed-element
with my-tabs.
It should look like this.
So, my-tabs.css
and my-tabs.html.
Great.
Next, let's talk
about dependencies
for creating our element.
So, this is Bower.
It's a package manager that can
be used to install and manage
front end dependencies.
Before you can begin
working on your element,
you'll want to make sure
you have Bower installed.
Follow the instructions
on the Bower site
for installing the tool.
If you have Node.js
installed, this
can typically be done
by running this command.
Bower will install all the
different modules we'll need.
You can now install
the dependencies
needed by untitled
element by running
bower install from
the my-tabs directory.
Navigating back a level, this
will add a few dependencies
to your development directory,
Polymer, the web component
polyfills, and one or two
others we'll be using for docs.
You're now ready to begin
working on the my-tabs element.
So, here's what the boilerplate
seed-element ships with,
looks right out of the box.
For my-tabs, we won't
directly be using JavaScript.
So you can add the noscript
attribute to our element.
This informs Polymer
that we won't
want to interact with JavaScript
for this particular element.
Now, a tab element
can actually be
built using a number of
existing Polymer elements.
And this is pretty powerful.
You can compose whole
elements and apps
from elements written
by other people.
You can find our
existing elements
over on the Polymer site
at the following address.
For example, core-selector
is an element
that manages a list of
items that can be selected.
They can be divs, spans,
or something else.
Here's a quick example
of it in action.
You can select items in a list
and trigger an active state
on them.
Magical.
So you can install
this element for use
in my-tabs using
the following line.
It'll then go and fetch
your dependency from Bower.
Once installed, you can
reference this new import
inside of my-tabs.
So core-selector can now
be used in this page.
Next inside of your element
definition at the line,
extends="core-selector".
This tells Polymer
that you'd like
to extend the functionality
of the selector element.
This lets us get its
functionality for free.
Quick note.
Styles defined
within your element
get scoped, meaning they don't
leak into the rest of the page.
Shadow DOM lets us let
in as much or as little
of the outside
world as we choose.
In this case, our
styles are scoped
within the confines of
the my-tabs element.
We can use this fact to apply
a little bit of Flexbox magic
inside our element.
Now we're going to add in one
more import called layout.html,
which is basic and
will allow our element
to be a Flex container.
A Flex container is
basically an element
that might contain
children, in our case, tabs,
that we'd like to make flexible.
One thing the Polymer
team believe in,
in this brave new world
of Web Components,
is that everything
is an element.
That's one reason we're
implementing these concepts
as elements.
It's pretty powerful when you're
just configuring components
using attributes.
So going back to
my-tabs, you want
to enable a way
to render children
of your my-tabs element
to define individual tabs.
So working with these
guys, the child elements.
Now this is achieved by
adding in the shadow tag
inside of your template.
These represent something called
a Shadow DOM insertion point.
Now Shadow DOM refers to
the ability of the browser
to include a sub-tree
of DOM elements
into the rendering
of a document,
but not into the main
document DOM tree.
This provides CSS and
DOM encapsulation.
Fantastic.
So now we have the final version
of the code for our custom tab
element.
Before we can use
our new tab element,
you'll want to edit demo.html
to add in the relevant markup.
So let's highlight them.
This is what it looks
like with my-tabs in place
before we've added any
actual tabs to our element.
Check that any references
to seed-element now point
to my-tabs.html instead.
Next, we add in the markup for
three new tabs inside our tabs
element.
Here we're just using
some simple spans.
So each span
represents a new tab.
Great.
So let's see what we've built.
Go and run a new preview
server at the command line
to preview your
new custom element.
And boom, there we have
the my-tabs element.
It's beautiful and
it's functional.
You can now reuse this
element across pages
with encapsulation
and a clean markup.
I've never seen anything
that looks so elegant.
Now that we've created
our my-tabs element,
let's deploy it to
GitHub pages so you
can share it with your friends.
Elements can be
shared, but we'll
be working with two branches,
master and GitHub pages.
We want to ensure that
our master branch contains
the bare minimum
of code that needs
to be consumed by
other apps or elements.
Now your GitHub pages branch
should contain a landing page
and checked independencies,
demos, and documentation.
First, create a new repository
on GitHub for your element.
And push the source for
my-tabs to this repository.
Navigate back to your
development directory
from the terminal.
And create a new temporary
directory and CD into it.
Next, grab a copy of Polymer's
Official Helper Tools.
You can git clone them using
the following one liner.
Great.
You should now have the
tools on your system.
Take note of where
they've been cloned to.
Finally, run the gp.sh script
found in the tools directory,
passing in your GitHub username
and the name of your element.
This will create
a gh-pages branch
on GitHub containing
a landing page
for your element and a
link to a demo for it.
It'll also include all of
the dependencies needed
to preview your element live.
Great.
So this is where my
landing page is now live.
And if you've been
following along,
yours should be live on
a very similar address
with your username
instead of mine.
Let's take a closer
look at the page.
It's pretty.
Our landing page can contain
examples and a summary
of the attributes and events
supported by our element.
Now these are all straight
from comments in our code.
And if your friend's click the
demo button at the very top,
it'll take them straight
to your demo page.
And there we go.
Tabs.
Our element is both beautiful,
functional, and awesome.
Hooray, I feel like
a real engineer now.
Web Components with Polymer
present an incredibly exciting
step forward for re-usability.
And there's a whole
world of elements
out there just
waiting to be built.
To get started, go check
out polymer-project.org .
Now go out and help
componentize the web today.
Thank you.